was ist da
ach du scheibenkleister das sind
thermofinke Stylefaktor und ich eine
Adresse
in Zürich sind
richtig Zürcher Innenstadt Bahnhof
Stadelhofen
einfach nur so kleine
ich suche Falkenstraße
[Musik]
das freut mich sehr aber ich muss nicht
mit tanzen wenn du willst kannst du
schon nein ich habe das gesehen das wäre
wie wenn ein Pony und Araber Pferden
tanzen würden übrigens meine Frau wir
sind verheiratet was ihr seid
verheiratet nein wirklich okay
sehr wichtig warum also meine Füße
bleiben sehr warm mit diesem ja schöne
Objekte
das heißt du bist eine der besten
schöne Dinge zusammen
[Musik]
50 Tänzerinnen und Tänzer sind deren
Truppen Zürich
[Musik]
jetzt ist der Moment für die Schuhe
super weil das tut weh und also in der
Moment die Füße können endlich
entspannen und ein ganzen Tag mit
Spitzenschuhe es kann natürlich weh tun
aber sieht auch anstrengend aus also ich
meine körperliche auch oder was ist
schwierig mit unserem Kunst ist das wir
müssen immer zeigen keine Erfolg also
alle meine Anstrengungen
also sehr natürlich und eine lagen haben
aber dann auch wenn es schon anstrengend
natürlich
[Musik]
also meine Erfahrung
kommen hier
ab 1920 von Junior Paletten
und die haben schon Probleme überall
eigentlich es gibt nicht ein Problem
Schmerzen gehören dazu
ja es kann sein dass ich einen Tag ohne
Schmerz habe und dann bin ich sehr froh
aber ja ich merke mit mit meiner alten
jeden Tag es gibt etwas und die Sachen
die kommen die bleiben aber ich liebe
meinen Job noch obwohl es halt ist und
z.B heute Abend wenn ich auf der Bühne
bin bin ich sehr sehr
froh und dass ich fühle mich frei und
ähm ja dann man sieht dort das Publikum
und wie kann man Applaus dazu und das
ist wirklich toll dieses Gefühl auf der
Bühne zu sein und
vielleicht deswegen
[Gelächter]
der Alltag ist durentaktet Punkt halbe
zwei
haben aber schauen wir es gibt so ein
ich dachte ihr dürft alle nur
Joghurt essen nein
zwei Kinder
sechs Monate und du und ich habe deinen
Bauch gesehen
ja ich habe ein Glück glaube ich auch
also ich natürlich habe viel gearbeitet
so zurück in meinem Körper zu sein aber
ja ich glaube wir haben so ich habe
gesagt ihr habt so viele Jahre unter mir
wo ich so viel gearbeitet habe dass ich
die da eine Erinnerung in unserem Körper
und das hilft
unglaublich so so schnell zu sein wieder
bei der Arbeit aber schwanger
en das das ist auch schön wenn ich
Bestellungen haben ich probiere Zeit zu
genießen mit den Kindern weil sie schon
schwierig nicht am Abend dort zu sein
und so etwas zumindest ich habe ein
bisschen Zeit am Nachmittag verdienen ja
Leute und Profitänzerin Julia
es paar Stunden
da ist meine Frau
weil ich ein bisschen erkältet bin
das ist eine Garderobe ja das ist das
ist unsere Garderobe vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr Licht oder ja
wenigstens okay
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es Ballett über die Vergänglichkeit mit
magischen Bilder
was der Daniel julia und ihre Truppen
zeigen ist schlicht weil klasse
[Musik]
[Applaus]
thank you so much
wow
unglaublich italienisch
Kolumbien sie hat sich irgendwann
entschieden zum Aufhören mit dem Tanzen
genau
[Musik]
das ist klar
definitiv fertig
als Profitänzerin
[Musik]
und Maskenbildner
mit über 300 Aufführungen
[Musik]
etwas wir müssen eine zweite Kurier
finden Karriere finden also das ist
immer hinter dem Kopf und ich glaube das
ist auch eine Chance finde ich
hüttprobe
Nina Gruppe dancer
und Daniel neben
[Musik]
Beauty
aber mit dem beiga
[Musik]
das ist ein typischer Tänzerinnen du
hast den Dinge haben also weil wir
brauchen das so dass wir keine Schmerzen
haben also wenn ich zu weit ja wir
müssen mit dieser solche Dinge bleiben
weil sonst nicht so schön meine Magen
aber ja ich brauch das ist eine sehr
wichtige
ein paar
okay zum ersten Mal im Leben
verboten
und dann musst du eigentlich
ein Mädchen war ja ich wollte immer das
war mein Traum und ja ich bin auf dem
Bauernhof aufgewachsen was du weit weg
und meine Mutter hat gesagt
ich war so aber sie hat recht gehabt
also mein Vater ist eine Physiker meine
Mutter sie hat Philosophie studiert
ich werde sicher Universität gehen
mit 15 16 habe ich begonnen zu denken oh
schade es wäre vielleicht schön
zu probieren und ich war schon zu alt
also es war wirklich eine ja ja es ist
ein bisschen eine
ach du meinst aber mir tut es richtig
weh wenn ich besser sieht super schön
aus aber wenn ich das jetzt wenn du so
auf die Zehen gehst dann denke ich oh
mein Gott nein nein ich glaube es ist
normal für uns
das ist unsere viele Jahre
[Musik]
finden Daniela
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja nein also das Problem mit meinem
kleinen es er hatte diese
srv-virus und was passiert jetzt ist das
er ist ein bisschen schwach in seinem
jünger und jetzt jedes Mal dass er krank
ist dass du das
trotzdem funktionieren oder also du hast
dein Kind zu Hause du machst dir Sorgen
aber hier
es ist auch Leben Realität und manchmal
wenn sie krank sind das ist schwierig
hier zu sein und alles zu vergessen
diese zwei Welten was du Mutter sein und
solo Tänzerin am Ballett das passt
eigentlich nicht zusammen oder ja nein
weil meine Kinder geben mir so viel und
das bringt mir in eine andere Welt das
geht mir Kraft für diese Welt für meine
Umgebung es beeindruckt mich wie Julia
Spagat schafft zwischen Mutter und
Ballerina sie als eine von der ersten
jetzt nimmt es mir wundern ob der Daniel
okay
[Musik]
ein bisschen geschlafen und das Gefühl
ist schon ein bisschen besser ja
bisschen mehr Energie wenn du nicht ganz
fit bist bist du besonders nervös dann
auch oder
ja ein bisschen mehr also ja ich muss
meine Energie ein bisschen mehr sparen
und das das ist nicht so ja das ist
nicht so ein gutes Gefühl aber es ist so
und ich versuche professionell zu
bleiben und ich gebe meine beste und äh
schauen wir wie das geht ja was machst
du jetzt noch was hast du für eine
Routine ja ein bisschen Zeit für mich
selber ein bisschen
er ist der Bruder von Anna Karina also
und er ist ein bisschen
sag mir das so gar nicht treu
also
in den schwierigen Beziehung
ich bin gar nicht so aber
nicht sehr gerne
gute Besserung
hallo auf der Punkt
[Musik]
seine Kombination von
halt vorne und
nicht zu weich in der Mitte ein Moment
und das kann sehr stressig sein manchmal
für eine denn eine Hauptrolle tanzen
musste es ist wirklich oh Gott
jetzt
ich glaube jetzt
verivo die wir müssen weg sind Kostümen
alles also ja dann lassen Sie sich in
Ruhe ja super okay
15 Minuten bis zum Beginn der
Vorstellung dies ist das second call 15
minutes
Julia schnell Ihre Spitzenschuhe andere
holen sich beim speziellen
[Musik]
bringt das Glück
ich dachte am Anfang
[Musik]
der Daniel aus Schwerenöter vergnügt
sich mit seiner husargestellten und wird
werden
[Musik]
während irmina vor verschieden
er
[Applaus]
es war wunderbar
ich habe nicht gespielt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]